hey everyone it's Micha BOS and welcome
to the Delta scalper analysis for Friday
July 28
2017 you know I've been creating these
videos on the Delta scalper almost every
day this week I think I I missed Monday
but um again you know I I want people to
see it every day right I I don't want
you to think that I just post a chart
here and there of of of a nice trade you
know I'm trying to show it to you every
day so you can see it and make a
decision and see if it's going to be
useful in your trading or not you know
everyone trades differently everyone has
different time frames they're trading
everyone has different chart types
they're trading and again I'm trying to
show you all the the different
combinations you know different chart
types different uh range different time
base charts and different contracts so
you know you can make an informed
decision if you want to pick this up for
your trading so this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk and it's not
for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
there are risks in trading you know you
can lose
money there you know I've said it you
know I mean you know people don't want
to admit it but that's that's the cold
hard truth you know I mean when you're
an individual Trader you can can lose
you know everything you put
in so the tools used in this
presentation are the Delta scalper uh go
to
www.as scaler.com
so first I'll talk about the crude oil
it's 9 987 tick chart okay um you
obviously the the one that stands out is
this big trade here early in the morning
you know was there anything else no
nothing here um so 7 you know 74 5 got a
sell didn't work out here at 830 got a
sell you it started going the direction
then snap back really quick but then you
know uh 855 you got a nice buy here from
you know 4940 all the way up to
75 the sell started to work up and it
came right back up the sell
again it's not the greatest winner but
again you know if the Market's only
giving you 15 ticks take your 15
ticks um late in the day you got you
know this sell didn't really work out a
little sell here a little buy
here now again you know that's the 987
tick chart you know and if you look at a
5 minute it's a bit different you know
overnight you had a sell here that
worked out over the next hour or so and
you got to buy here it started to work
and boom We got slammed right here
here's a sell you got a little bit here
you don't getch this move on the 5minute
chart well you got it on the uh 987
chart then 1:00 you got a nice buy here
little sell here this one you know right
on the close so again you know that's
that's the five minute chart you know I
just showed you the 987 tick chart and
really quick this is the eight range
chart uh wasn't very productive on an
eight range chart you got a small winner
here not much here this one definitely
is a
loser then you know up here at this High
you get a nice little move um you know
so it was it was a it was a struggle you
know it's it's uh
it reminds me of you know watching Tiger
Woods when he used to be a a better
golfer than he is now but um you know
you you'd see him
drive on the tea and drive he'd shank
his his t- shot off somewhere and he's
got to play catchup and just struggle to
make par this is the type of chart that
uh you know is is like that you kind of
you know you get a nice little shot here
and then you know you're getting your up
and down you know you're trying to get
it all right you know bad shot here bad
shot here but then hopefully you could
get something back here to save power
for the
day okay so next up I'm going to talk
about the dexs a bit here now I'm going
to explain something um about the
settings
so um yeah I've really explained you the
settings and and what it looks like on
when you make some adjustments now
really the the only setting that you're
really want to play around with is this
look back bars and you know here the
default is set to seven
and if if you want to filter out you
know some of these trades like you know
these you know that aren't very
productive sometimes you know like this
one here
um you can change it right it's set at
seven so you can see here you got a buy
here you this one works you know these
sells don't really go anywhere this buy
doesn't really go anywhere if you
stretch it out to a higher number like
this is 20 okay this chart I I'll just
put them side by side so it's a bit
easier to understand
that's so this is whoops it's the seven
what am I
doing sorry um you
know I I don't have a professional uh
videographer or anything like that you
know I just make these videos um you
know at the end of the day so you know
just to help you you see it so if just
bear with me again you know sorry my
production cost is is zero um
but uh so again you know the the you
know changing the setting right this is
seven this chart here on the right on
the left it's set at
20 so it's going to filter out some of
these uh trades that aren't very
effective and there's going to be less
trades with the higher uh setting of 20
so you could see are you getting better
trades you know here you just get this
one you get this one you know which is
you get you know that's that one and
that's that one but it cuts out some of
these shitty trades
trades you know then you don't have
anything else for a while here then you
get another sell here that's at
451 um so it cuts out you know
this this trade here it cuts out this
trade so it does cut out some winners
but more importantly it cuts out the
losers or I say the losers but it cuts
out you know a bit of losers here on the
way back up you have this losing trade
here you don't it's not showing up when
you have it set at 20 so you know that
that that's a setting that I like to use
sometimes on on volatile markets um you
know I said the further you set it out
now here you get this buy that fails um
this one this is 735 that's this trade
here you know it's just a way to filter
out um you know some of the less
effective trades and you don't get the
buy here that you have here but you got
those two cells here
it's
better so you don't get this trade here
that you had here you know which
resulted in a nice trade honestly but
again you look how many how many losing
trades you've cut out already you know
here you get a nice winner here you get
another nice
winner whereas this area right here is
this area here so you don't have these
trades you don't have them there but
again you got this one you got this one
but if you're looking at this one set at
70 at 7 rather um you you get the sell
here right after you get the buy but
here it's not even appearing on this
chart so um you know that that's a
setting you can you can use and you know
experiment with you know then sell sell
so you know overall which which chart do
you think perform
better you know the one with the setting
set to seven or the one was set set to
uh 20
you cuz when you set at seven you're
getting some losing
trades you're getting more losing trades
you're getting more trades for one but
you're getting more you're getting some
more extra losing trades right and you
know every time you have a losing trade
it sort of drains on you but when it's
set to 20 I mean how many losing trades
do you have here let's see this is a
winner winner
winner
winner small
winner winner winner
winner loser I mean is mostly winners
you know you've got rid of um some of
those borderline trades by setting it at
a at a higher um at a higher look back
period now you know what the look back
period does obviously when it says look
back period it's analyzing the the last
seven bars versus the last 20 bars so if
you set it the 20 it's analyzing the
last 20
bars as opposed to the last seven
bars so you know that's something you
can play around with um I said the
default is set to seven I I use that on
majority of my charts um but you know
markets that move around fast you know
NASDAQ is a good example da mini da um
Dax obviously you know try it with a
with a higher
number rather than the default you know
but the default I have on pretty much
every every chart even the charts that I
have it changed to 20 I also keep a
seven open you know just for uh
for references you know I want to know
what's uh what it looks like and what
what it's
doing okay so uh
snps want to jump into the snps so this
is the setting again
one just a normal default settings got a
nice little winner here winner there
winner there winner there this one
stopped you out a nice move up here you
know something here so you again you
know it's giving you some nice trades
here
and okay so that's the
uh what is that this the four
range now again you know here's a here's
a one minute chart this one set to 20
okay it's on the e- minis look at this I
mean it's just you know up up down a
little bit this one just it came right
back down immediately before shot up
this one's sort of
sideways yeah you got that nice move
here you know it's trying to get
something going here and here but you
know the market just wasn't having it
and that's you know the cash open now uh
I want to show you the 980 but that's a
set at 20 I mean I could show you the
one minute if I could dig it out but
it's just probably just going to have
some more um more trades that are
probably just you know some winners and
losers mixed in there but again you know
why is it important is because again if
you
can filter out trades that include a lot
of losing trades you know mentally
you're going to be better off
right okay so this is the 987 chart 987
tick chart in S&P so what do you got you
got a nice move here sideways here
sideways here a nice move lower you know
68 down to 64 actually went lower down
to
63 um a little bit of a move there
before it SN back and then a buy
here yeah this is that difficult area
where as soon as you get the buy it just
comes right back down on you pretty
quick um a little bit of a sell here
again you know this is after the cash
close
already um
eurocurrency I think I showed you this
in the other my other video but again
you it's the F minute chart you're
getting some nice not some nice trades
cuz you know even though it looks like
all big bars it's actually quite
uh quite not not a big movement day but
again you know from
11727 all the way up to 40 plus and then
another nice move here little move you
know you get some decent moves here in
the Euro currencies um this one failed
but then again you know nice decent move
here from this 80 I what you want call
it 84 area down into the
70s so you getting some decent trades
there in the euro currency see if I can
dig up a Japanese Yen chart
here and I want the eight range chart in
the Yen just bear with me
here what happened to
it so again it's
um yeah here let's just go back so it's
like oh gosh um
okay you get a nice move here again I'm
going from the back forward because I
want to show you you know this is losing
trade here this
one you try to stop you're did okay if
you don't you're you're stopped out this
one you nice little move up this
one difficult one you probably would
have Trail your sto and got out at a
small loss got a winner here but uh
again you know it's like know this area
is difficult right sometimes you're
going to run into areas of difficulty
but you know if you come
back going back to you know you catch
this move here you know a move from 45
all the way up to 75 80 Happy Days right
happy days that's what you want you know
you get a nice little move here you know
nice little move there so you're getting
some areas of difficulty but then you
know that's fine you could deal with
these areas of difficulty if you're
getting you know these big moves like
this you know that that's what you want
but you know sometimes you just got to
sit through the the the crappy um the
crappy trades I mean I I I hate to say
it but you know sometimes the the market
is just you know shitty um you know
you're trying to trade it and you know
it's just jumping up and down it's just
facilitating trade that's what the
markets do but it's it's going to be
difficult at those times you just got to
sit through it it's just like going out
on a on a date with a with a girl you
don't get along with you know yeah you
can just end the date and say Hey you
know [__] it let's you know obviously
it's not working out but you know be a
gentleman and see see the date through I
was going to throw this chart up there I
haven't talked about this indicator this
is the transition indicator different
than the Delta scalper but you know I
mean people have it sometimes ah it's
not that good blah blah blah you know
but then they don't want to send me
charts you know if you send me charts
sometimes I can work with you and and
help you with the settings but you know
you're getting nice trades here
here here here you know it just kills me
because sometimes you know people say oh
yeah you I lost on this trade well you
got in here and they got out down here
well why didn't you get out you know on
the move down rather than let it stop
you out but again you know that that
just comes with you know understanding
how to trade the markets I think you
know Trail your stops you know not every
don't tra treat every trade as you know
it's either got to go to the profit
Target or stop me out you know that
that's that's the whole idea of trailing
your stop is you know once the market
turns and
is starting it it's move in the opposite
direction so sort of hit its apex of the
high of the trade and then it's going to
come down then you know get out so this
is uh lastly I'll just show you this
this is the mini doll this is the Delta
Scupper the uh 100 tick chart very fast
moving
chart but really let's take a look from
the cash open so here boom right off the
cash open get a nice trade boom you're
done turn off your computer go out and
play with the dog
um follows up with a loss get a nice
little small winner here another loss
there um you know a losing trade here
but you know something here nice winner
nice winner nice winner you know
straight down straight back up then you
know another nice trade
up you know sort of this difficult area
in here then another nice winner
here another nice winner here after this
trade we get probably stopped out
and that was it for the day so again you
know whether you're using a fast moving
chart or a slow moving chart it's giving
you you know you got different options
on you know what you want to use it with
so you know again thanks for watching
this video go to Deltas scaler.com to
learn more about it thanks bye-bye